it seems like there's this
infantilization
and simultaneous
feminization of our societies and
cultures and politics actually that
really seems to be what's going on I
think that's the shift from
individuality to collectivism
um you know intense push for
quote-unquote political correctness
beyond beyond a reasonable amount right
we're not just saying hey don't don't
cut don't scream racial slurs at people
but you know people wanting to redefine
every single word wanting to have safe
spaces and Trigger warnings and
everything is offensive and everything
is toxic you know men men just talking
just us having this conversation you
know this is some type of unhealthy or
dangerous interaction it's all wrapped
in the safety language we need to keep
everyone safe safe it's not about
Freedom Liberty responsibility rights
you know equality of opportunity it's no
no no we need we need Equity everyone
needs to get the same thing
um in fact we need to silence people and
censor people who even dare ask
questions uh you know a man acting like
a man or boy acting like a boy is toxic
but at the same time women should be
acting like men it's like there's it's
just like there's hundreds of these
narratives out there all at once but
you're kind of hitting the population
and I think it's I mean I think it's
literally driving people insane like I
think people are genuinely becoming
mentally ill and are having all sorts of
issues and identity issues and confusion
and some of it doesn't surprise me
because identity itself just seems to be
under under attack like people don't
even know who they are anymore I think
young boys are growing up in the world
wondering I mean you know what what does
it even mean to be a boy what does it
even mean to be a man uh women are
growing up you know the question of what
a woman even is is now is now in
question right it's it's all being
undermined so I think there's just a lot
of confusion especially amongst younger
people when I when I talk to them or see
them interacting online and it just
seems like they don't really know
their their place in the world I think
if you're a 16 or 17 year old boy or
girl in this world right now it's not
that clear what your path in life is
supposed to be you know for all its
flaws in the past it was very it was
always clear it was always clear okay
you're a man this is what you do you're
a woman this is what you do and if you
do these things you will you know you're
almost not guaranteed but you have a
very high probability that you're gonna
find uh you know you're going to attract
a mate and you're going to have a family
and it's gonna just generally work out
whereas now it's like there's all these
different paths you can take and there's
all these mixed signals and I don't know
it just seems like very it seems very
deranging I'm quite glad to not be I
don't know 20 years younger than I am in
this world right now yeah it's funny I
was thinking about this the other day
because it always seems like our parents
generation and our grandparents
generation would say things like well I
grew up in the best generation maybe
that was right for them but I thought
about it the other day maybe it's my age
you know at this point but I really
think that I had one of the best
childhoods that I could possibly have
you know the best experiences at that
period of uh time compared to today like
I I
you know I feel sorry for some of these
kids
um you touched on a lot of things there
and it's like I get exactly what you're
saying and it's difficult to have these
conversations and it's strange you know
because I've followed you for the last
year or two I think on Twitter and
you're one of the nicest guys when it
comes to approaching these conversations
from a balanced perspective logical
um and people still come at you pretty
hard right
um I'm not I'm not quite as nice as you
sometimes on Twitter but that's just me
um but yeah there is a general
feminization of the West uh it's it's
softening the Western male there's a lot
of things that contribute to it I mean
you could spend hours talking about
what's going on and how that's going on
um there's everything from estrogenics
placed in environmental Foods packaging
and even in tap water there's estrogen
and tap water uh to just the way people
behave as a result of cultural media and
marketing all that sort of stuff I mean
I never lived in a time where I've seen
so many men want to transition to become
women and to me that's the ultimate
expression of the feminization of
culture men wanting to change their
actual gender to the other gender so
it's a bizarre thing to behold but it's
it's a reality of the world that we live
in today that's that is the loudest
possible message that young boys and men
are hearing today
um is be softer be kinder be be all of
these things that really men aren't I
mean if you look at boys in their
natural habitat like if you look at a
four or five six-year-old boy that's
about as Alpha as you know most men ever
get today right like they'll like
they'll go to the sandbox and pick up a
handful of sand and just whip it at
somebody for fun because you know they
want to dominate or whatever they'll you
know they'll be on their bicycle and
they'll try like high-speed runs at
things like when we were kids we used to
build ramps and jump into all these guns
and weird things it's like that's what
that's what boys do
or or did naturally you know to sort of
compete and test you know test one
another
um but that's not encouraged anymore
it's you know participation ribbons for
everybody there's no first place last
place there's uh you know we live in
strange times don't we yeah we we really
do and it's fascinating you said that
because you know I'm not a father yet
but I I'm an uncle of 10 and I'm blessed
to have five nephews and five nieces and
for all the people who think that these
gender differences are just socially
constructed like please honestly hang
out with some children go to a go to a
nursery school just watch their behavior
um the boys and girls are different and
they're totally different interests and
and the difference is it's not just okay
it's good yeah this is the thing that
would that's the thing that we've gotten
away from it's like people are trying to
solve problems that are not problems to
begin with right I I sometimes have
maybe we have too much peace you know
one of the things I've come to accept
and realize about humanity is that we're
we're a warring primate you know we
really are we're very similar to
chimpanzees you know chimpanzees will
actually go out and wage war on
neighboring tribes that might be
infringing on their territories and you
know I was looking at this um
infographic once and it basically had
you know the big long timeline and a
peppered series of dots of Wars around
the world and it's recently like in the
last 100 years you know essentially you
know setting aside the second first
world war we live in one of the most
peaceful times in history and it only
seems like we have easy access to
nutrition easy access to transportation
we have easy access to anything that
they didn't have to deal with a thousand
years ago they had real struggles back
then and maybe all the spare time
created this I don't know it's difficult
to put my finger on it but it seems it
seems clear as day that it's going on
yeah you're correct we live in this
world of paradoxes I mean I would say
that the things that seem to be becoming
less accessible to people are meaning
and purpose and genuine Community right
I mean loneliness is at an all-time high
uh people are having fewer children and
forming fewer families than ever before
mental illness is at an all-time high
self-harm suicide like all these all
these things obesity I mean if you look
at the West the thing that's fascinating
is what's happened is
uh and you you sort of touched on this
but the majority of the social problems
are now a result of excess
yeah so in in most of the world and all
throughout human history the problem was
always lack right there was there was
there wasn't enough to go around there
wasn't enough resources uh you know
there were there were famines and
droughts and pestilence and people
didn't have medicine women were dying in
childbirth right it was always the
problem was always lack if you think of
all the stuff we're talking about it's
actually the result of so much comfort
so much excess that I mean you know no
one in the no one in the USA is starving
how many people are eating themselves to
death though right that's unheard of
Imagine a century ago imagine going back
even one century ago and explaining that
there are going to be millions of people
who are eating so much food that it's
killing them they wouldn't imagine
putting somebody in a time machine from
10 000 years ago and showing them your
video of deadlifting into the world's uh
you know the world record for women's
you know heaviest deadlift and then
explaining to them how many views that
got and why that happened they would
think the world gone completely insane
like if you go to a gym today and you
see people going there picking up things
putting them down running on a treadmill
in one spot and showing that to a guy
from 10 000 years ago he'd think that
the world's gone completely nuts and
want to go back I would think right like
wasting calories and and energy doing
nothing when they would have been
spending their time you know making sure
they had food and protection and shelter
I really hope you guys enjoyed that clip
if you want to watch the full length
podcast you can find that over here that
clips from if you're new to the channel
make sure you hit subscribe over here
and pin down below in the top comment
you'll find a bunch of useful links to
my website my supplement line books and
a bunch of other stuff have an amazing
day peace out